Now that you know a few design principles, and
how to compose graphics, let's go through a few different narrative
structures that you can use to walk your viewers through your visualization.
>> In addition to narrative structures,
I'll teach you about the data collection process and data processing.
I'll also show you some examples of bias, and
what you should avoid when creating graphics.
>> In all the visualizations we've created and encountered in this class,
one thing that was absent, was any idea of context or narrative.
Often when you're reading a newspaper, a blog post, or
an article, there's some story that connects all the pieces together.
Think of narrative as the invisible string that ties the frames of
a movie together, or the binding of a book that glues the pages together.
Let's walk through how journalists approach this problem and
create stories of their own.